hi I'm Aubrey Plaza and I'm here to tell
you about my new movie called the to do
list that's coming out in theatres this
Valentine's Day it's not like all those
other lame Valentine's Day movies that
tries to impress you with an all-star
cast it's a real Valentine's Day movie
about love [__] [__] why so many
jobs it's about deep feelings who is
that just a wobble that is my type no
you have it tight you imagine losing
your feet hard to a college guy mutual
respect this shorts or skirt either
there's sports family dumbass
door to the back door not the back door
there's doors we don't do the back doors
one of us and above all communication
it's a lot harder than you think
okay down his head hmm yeah okay yeah
right there looking for my keys keys now
I mean Valentine's Day romantic
[Music]
so grab your special someone and come
see the to-do list happy Valentine's Day
everyone on Valentine's Day not now
because it's not Valentine's Day right
now but it will be
[Music]